now to ukraine and new allegations of
possible war crimes officials there say
an attack by russian forces on two
schools killed three people and wounded
12 in the northern part of the country
ukrainian president volodomir zielenski
responded by saying all russian
commanders who give such orders are
simply sick and incurable deborah patta
is in ukraine which is now in its 11th
week of war
fury on the battlefield what russia has
lacked a military strategy so far it
makes up for with brute force
and a seemingly endless supply of deadly
artillery before russian shells rained
down on these buildings they were full
of chattering students their future now
up in smoke
what's the point of destroying schools
last ukraine's vladimir's
any russian commander he gives such an
order is sick
in mario paul's as of style steel plant
those ukrainian soldiers barricaded
inside astoundingly continue to hold off
russian troops with every bit of reserve
they have left
and in harkiev ukraine continues to push
russia back but for its civilians
it's been over 11 weeks of endless
misery
in the village of stepanke 52 year old
olga karpenko's daughter could not hide
from a russian tank that fired directly
at her house
and it's still not completely safe to
exhume her daughter's body as she
relives the trauma
she didn't die straight away she said
she suffered for almost a whole day all
she has left now is heartbreak for cbs
morning's debra para kiev ukraine